oh I didn't look at my view last night I
thought there was gonna be like a big
reveal to say guys I'm in Pittsburgh but
it was just a building but that's where
I am I'm in Pittsburgh I'm filming
something really really fun so usually I
don't actually get to spend much time in
the city but today I've got a day off
and I'm going to hang with my friend Dez
who you may remember if you guys have
been fans of my channel for a long time
we used to make videos together back in
the day when I lived here so I'm kind
enough to meet her we're going to an
afternoon showing of Star Wars which I'm
so excited about because all of my
friends have seen it without me I've
been super busy these past few weeks so
I had zero chance to see it but today
I've got day off and I can't wait we're
also gonna go to Target and probably go
to Starbucks so come along for the ride
where's the other shoe how am I gonna
make a montage starting off my video
with one shoe I look like a bee Suri
[Music]
back in Pittsburgh baby oh my god I love
the city I love the people I love
everything about it and I especially
love it it's the holiday season because
there's Christmas decorations up it's so
festive it's so amazing I'm super
excited I'm also going to see Star Wars
I am like a child I am I am a child
basically I think we're gonna go to
Target first cuz I gotta get some items
in place and turn left under William
fireplace by GPS got through you lost
we're on track
I forgot to pack a bigger bag - the bag
that I have is so tiny like it basically
can only fit a mopey charger and my
phone in it which that's not ideal so I
need to get some jammies oh there's
that's a dress that is not jammies just
it's incredible so I think this is
perfect unless I found a Star Wars
backpack so far I haven't seen one yet
does this here hi
so I was like dad's I'm at Target I'm in
a little boy section looking for some
webpage she's like looking for little
boys is like no shopping for myself I
was looking for Star wear sweat pants
and look at this they actually have girl
star wars what pants those are so soft
look at these ones I forgot to my pants
I've been sleeping in the hotel with so
cool okay that's one of the things in
the list some brands having a Christmas
party and she said that we could like
better Christmas sweaters or onesies oh
gosh there's a Chewbacca over here wowee
I think I'm just gonna wear my r2d2
sweater why are they boys section let us
let us ladies have have some fun - I
mean I wasn't even like trying to go
shopping I just wanted a few items it
doesn't actually work that well that's a
future video that Roe and I filmed but
it's not out yet so stay tuned last
thing on the list can I get a retail can
I get a redo I'm putting the lotion and
the best
because of course I would get the
popcorn with the porn bucket
Belson has bb-8 on it too which is
incredible so we just got out of Star
Wars and it was so good but why not well
that's crap because I thought it was
absolutely fantastic
I loved it now this is gonna be a good
segue into a video that I filmed a
little while ago but I never really had
a good place or so really who Star Wars
museum my friend owns a ton of digital
stores are some that is never seen the
light of day so let's cut to that but I
went through weeks ago this is Craig
hi Greg how are you can you explain to
them where we are right now and what's
going on because I feel like I did not
do it justice weird Carter Sexy's which
is one of the oldest art stores in LA
coincidentally the art store that sold
the guys at ILM the art supplies to
design the original Star Wars and I
tonight in doing a pop-up gallery of all
the artwork I own from the original
classic trilogy of Star Wars done by all
these famous artists to celebrate the
fact that I have a virtual museum that
any of you guys can go and visit which
is really cool I tried it out I was
picking up all of your pieces and
throwing which is something that you can
do in virtual reality but not in real
life but do you have a favorite piece
here is one of your most coveted with
other than this one that is you
every weird painting of you know is not
this was done by the legendary artist
Drew Struzan who did posters for all the
Star Wars movies he also did posters of
The Goonies and back to the future which
there's a movie poster you love drew I
had done some sculptures for Lucasfilm
that in collectible sculptures and I
needed to do a Star Wars box and be
awesome if Drew would do it and he did
and he painted me as an x-wing pilot to
go on the back of the box another fun
fact which is completely unrelated to
this I once got my arms ripped off in a
video with Tommy Wiseau and the man that
made those fake arms that's my claim to
fame I rip your arms crazy and oh my
gosh and the disaster on has just came
out - which was an incredible view but
that's a whole other story
what other few do you think is your
second base um can we go see the art
that I own from Star Wars I'm calling
this exhibit the lost art of Star Wars
because when they were making the movie
particularly the the first one in New
Hope no one thought that it would even
last two weeks in the theater so as all
the artists were working their heart out
doing all these drawings and designs if
something I rejected it just got torn up
or thrown away so this piece right here
is from Empire Strikes Back and it is
the trench on Hoth after the rebels were
defeated but Boba Fett is in the trench
I asked Joe Johnson why is bogus Boba
Fett
because he doesn't come into the story
till later yeah and it turns out that
designs for both offenses were actually
for this super trooper went before Lucas
even wrote the script he was like oh we
got a design these like super storm
trooper
I mean this is like I'm a Star Wars fan
but this is completely taking them all
to an entirely new level like this isn't
just absolutely incredible you guys see
one more thing that's incredible
paintings here and this collection
drawings right here are the first-ever
drawings done for Star Wars so if they
kind of had lunch Lucas like oh here's
my idea there's these good guys and bad
guys and and Collin came up with these
drawings and he said that the only thing
he knew for sure he had to do was make
the good guys in the bad guys
identifiable to the audience Wow
so these original paintings here before
anything that was strong just something
super simple you know just something I
put together over lunch you know no big
deal
thank you so much for sharing with us
now there's an entire VR experience do
you guys can actually see I'll put a
link in the description so if you guys
have a chance that'll work it's called
the sansar vehicle that we use and if
you have a vibrant oculus it's it will
see all this stuff really close you guys
gotta check it out okay bye okay now
we're back here hi des did you like it I
can't believe I have a bucket
what am I gonna do with this I got stuck
under the chair and it's now I got bent
on it so we are at furries holiday party
and I've got this incredible r2d2
sweater on and Brian hey Brian let me
see that sweater find your lack of cheer
so what I'm gonna do is I got these
little lights and I'm going to string
them through my sweater so that it'll be
like super festive I hope this works but
I'm really not sure if it's gonna I'm
ruining my sweater
[Music]
do the keys know you're driving why
would I have the keys
Wow Christmas that is all the time we're
going Christmas shopping
well basically only buying one thing
we're getting a grandmother and new
iPhone so I'm super excited about it but
it's Christmas youth so what are we
thinking camera is also gonna die so
I'll probably be continuing this vlog on
my iPhone like usual my camera has been
dying so fast it's actually crazy
there's got to be a new camera out soon
cuz this one is seen better days I'm
chilled to the core at least it's not
snowing like in Chicago a lot of snow
you can put our seated heated seats on
our CDs Wow is it Chili's it's actually
not that cold considering so Christmas
Eve at the mall let's see what it's like
everyone's probably not like yesterday
true everyone's probably spending time
with their family not come to the mall
we also have to go to Whole Foods
studies in your mom ah take this it's
like an empty mall
[Music]
so I completely forgot the new South
Hills Mall
yeah has a new Apple store where is it I
think it's the same place no they move
I'm actually not sure wait do you go to
build-a-bear because they have new Mario
builder bears I love smile off the ball
okay it's not here anymore
now it's advertisements
here it is look up look use your head
turn
it looks so good
[Music]
okay I'm walking it look at these doors
they're amazing they all just swing out
so this is like the new style of app
stores that they have the first one that
I saw like this was the one in New York
that they have like the whole World
Trade Center they have like huge screen
over here - what are you doing Jen
good here's the new I met curls so I
didn't even make a video because I
basically had all of my holiday videos
already planned but I did order the new
iMac Pro and if you guys want to guess
what I got I'll make a video about that
later but here it is a new matte-black
keyboard looks beautiful blending them a
little bit suspect about is this mouse
it's very glossy so that's going to
definitely pick up a lot of favorites
beautiful we got Grahams new iPhone I'm
also contemplating getting this
this is the best color ever don't do it
oh you're shaking your head no it's like
do you oppa should get the yellow cake
so good so festive for the holiday
season for the new year new year new me
I even got the watch band to match baby
[Music]
present for myself Merry Christmas
this is such a nice wholefoods this is
fairly new I know it's not exciting for
a bunch of you guys if you live in
California because we have them like on
every single straight corner but here
back home this is very nice will it fall
through we're gonna come back and get
this I'm gonna set no we will not forget
this is her mom
Oh
there's only three
[Music]
that's the saddest thing ever I was so
excited and I've only got three
this is such a I just got tripped
[Music]
well I think I pulled something in my
neck Christmas shopping is going well we
got our momma calendar just me thought
all hope was lost it has been regained
in the cooler section look at this how
many should I get probably like a lot
of aina moll
you were just about to leave and I
almost forgot to get to your planet it's
so cute could you imagine if you would
have taken off no because there was only
one left I
you wouldn't even known this is like the
highlight of the video other than the
phone and everything else I was so
excited about this cute little plate I
left in the car only
oh sorry you're right gosh where's keys
oh I gotta use keys no push to start
we're going to sheets I'm super excited
this is one of my favorites and gas
stations
you guys aren't from the East Coast you
might I forget what's the Philadelphia
one sounds all new these pumps actually
used to be over there this really this
is a really riveting content in trouble
they yell at me every single time I come
in here I film secret secret sheets what
are we getting Jen did you scream super
fancy okay what do we get these are like
the best gifts cuz they're super fun and
they provide a lot of entertainment and
potential money
no I'm trying to flip the camera around
but I can't because I've got gloves on
who's gonna get gas I hope what I can't
I can't get out what do we do I'll sit
all day until you pump the gas you think
that guy over there okay gas for us we
don't need a man I just need you to get
out and pump the gas for me don't be no
man
how much was it dirty dollars oh my
again the door
[Music]
[Applause]